- Originally owned by the daughter
of Marie Antoinette's governess,
this château is a trove of
hidden architectural gems.
About 30 miles outside of Paris
stands Château de Groussay.
Built in 1815, it remained a
family home until the 1930s
when it was bought by
an Italian arts patron
who made modifications including
Chinese inspired gardens,
the Tartar Tent and a theater.
The private mini theater
of Château de Groussay
opened in 1957,
and is inspired by a baroque
opera house in Germany.
Today it is still active
with plays and concerts
taking place throughout the year.
One of the châteaus most
admired features is the library.
It is said that it was
Cecil Beaton's inspiration
for the library in the film My Fair Lady,
but the most unusual feature
of all is the Tartar Tent,
a painted metal pavilion,
but made to look like a fabric tent;
the interior of which
features 10,000 delft tiles.
The château was declared a
historic monument in 1993,
and it's open to the
public for weekend visits,
or special events.
A walk through this château
really shows how the other half lived.